a federal jury convicted elizabeth
holmes on four of 11 charges for her
role in a years-long fraud scheme while
running her startup theranos over the
course of the high-profile trial the
prosecution set out to prove that holmes
intentionally misled investors and
patients about the efficacy of
theranos's blood testing technology
jurors heard from 29 government
witnesses and reviewed reams of
documents text messages emails and
reports
they also heard directly from holmes
herself who spent seven days on the
stand she acknowledged regrets but
maintained that she never defrauded
anyone the jury found her not guilty on
four other counts and failed to reach a
verdict on three counts with cameras
banned in the courtroom wsj's sarah
randazzo brings us all the highlights
from holmes's testimony
elizabeth holmes shocked a lot of people
when she took the stand what was the
defense's strategy in having her talk
she's good at working a room she's good
at convincing people it's what she had
done
her whole career she had convinced tons
of high profile investors and washington
luminaries and the like to buy into her
vision and really this was just the
ultimate sales pitch for taking the
stand to tell her side of the story in
the first part of her testimony the
defense walked the jury through the
early days of theranos
they painted her as an entrepreneur who
had great intentions and was really
trying to improve healthcare she said
she thought things were going well and
you know she'd get reports from a study
saying oh these results were excellent
and she wanted to share that with
investors and so she gave a lot of
examples of times when scientists and
others were telling her things were on
track
another big topic throughout the trial
holmes comments about her company's
relationship with the military here's a
clip prosecutors played of holmes
talking to investors in 2013. we built
the business around
our partnerships with pharmaceutical
companies and our contracts with the
military
wherein we could deploy
our framework a lot of investors said
that they backed theranos because of its
relationship with the military which
didn't exist
how did holmes answer to that she
basically insisted uh you know up down
and sideways that she did not recall
ever telling an investor that the
fairness device is being actively used
by the military and so it was this very
odd disconnect where we had heard from
several investors who said she said this
in pitches and that was a big thing that
we
you know that got us to invest holmes
explained that theranos was jointly
working on several studies with the us
department of defense but she
acknowledged that no military
partnerships ever resulted from the
studies another key moment came when
holmes conceded to one of the
key pieces of evidence she admitted to
altering theranos documents to include
the logos of major pharmaceutical
companies
investors testified that the doctored
reports helped convince them to buy into
the startup
and she said yes i i added the logos of
pharmaceutical companies to the top but
i didn't think that was misleading i
just thought it showed that this report
was done in consultation with the
pharmaceutical companies so she didn't
frame it in the same way the prosecution
did even as she said she was the one
responsible for it another key issue in
the trial was theranose's use of blood
testing devices made by other companies
prosecutors played this video clip of
holmes speaking with cnbc's jim cramer
in 2015. every test that we offer in our
laboratory can run on our proprietary
devices holmes falsely claimed theranos
could run more than 200 tests on its
proprietary device in reality the device
could only perform a dozen tests we
heard her basically say publicly for the
first time what they did with these
third-party devices and that yes they
bought third-party machines and modified
them so that they could run their tiny
blood samples that you know they said
were being run on their own proprietary
machines a pivotal moment in holmes's
testimony came when she claimed she had
suffered sexual and emotional abuse it
was of course very traumatic and and
serious allegations that she brought
saying that her former boyfriend sonny
belwani who was also her top deputy
theranos really controlled her life on a
micro level controlling when she could
sleep when she could eat
how she ran her business what she should
do to be a better business person and
even saying that he forced her to have
sex when she didn't want to sonny
balwani has denied the abuse allegations
prosecutors presented evidence in the
form of hundreds of text messages
between holmes and bahawani showing
loving exchanges
bahwani faces a separate trial next year
for the same fraud and conspiracy
charges as holmes he has denied the
allegations against him it really was
emotional powerful testimony
the problem was it didn't relate to the
fraud that was being alleged that it
happened she even explicitly said no i'm
not saying that sunny told me what to
tell investors and what to tell business
partners but she was saying he clouded
kind of everything about what she did in
the prosecution's cross-examination
holmes expressed remorse for how
theranos treated lab employees and
handled situations with reporters
prosecutors told jurors how theranos
threatened scientists with legal action
to keep them from talking to journalists
about problems at the lab holmes also
testified about her attempts to quash
wall street journal reporting the
journal broke story after story about
theranose's failed technology i think
the strategy there is to make her look
more human if you take the stand and say
i did nothing wrong i've never done
anything wrong in my life but a jury's
going to have a hard time relating to
that when she said things like the way
we handled the wall street journal
process was a complete disaster and yes
i really wish we had treated erica chan
one of the lab scientists better you
know we could have done that differently
it showed she was taking some
responsibility
holmes's final verdict could have a
lasting impact in the world of silicon
valley venture capital startups white
collar cases are very hard to bring
fraud is very hard to prove and you know
there's always a lot of questions over
whether it's worth it for the government
to bring a case like this and so this
could give other companies in silicon
valley pause but it certainly is notable
in that it's very rare um for startup
and startup culture to be considered a
crime what does this decision mean for
homes sentencing will follow we don't
know yet um you know what kind of
sentence she'll have but each wire fraud
count carries the maximum sentence of 20
years and so
she's looking at potentially years in
prison a lot of factors go into
sentencing it's really a complex matrix
where they take into account prior
convictions things like that which
obviously she doesn't have so
it'll be really interesting to see what
the judge does with sentencing